hello and welcome to this video playing
where they not that's a cool opponent at
some Grand Master Gawain Jones Duane
Jones what flag is that Cook Islands
okay so we'll see what mr. Jones is
going for he's 26 50 something like that
very high rated over the board I'm not
sure about the up and downs of the
ratings but very strong GM so we see
what he has in store against them my
mother gone offline check check yeah
this line this is this is a difficult
line in blitz chess it's um it's
something that is not considered to be
great in in long time controls but in
blitz this is a different matter the
dark squares are so weak and to us I
don't like it at all in blitz just down
it's very difficult to handle Lex plays
much easier so we'll see what happens
just what to do
let's go back there I'm absolutely ready
to return the exchange for its bishop
which might be necessary in some cases
for example John after takes takes
Bishop before I saw that but I don't I
don't mind really don't mind
check check oh I simply blundered the
porn that's not good wow I just blended
that bloody porn that's really really
bad
okay let's see what happens here 94 he s
actually still kind of interesting when
I can still I can take first this is
very relaxed about things here it seems
this is dangerous already at least i
think what is he doing now queen d false
blundering the bishop 9 f6 is a threat
is that so easy hmm ok jan ok so it
gives me that that bishop ok it's the
lightest stretch are the night strapped
somewhat trapped
that's nice OOP to d7 I can rupee
something that's not playable look f1 to
try to extort get it out there doesn't
work
jam hmm it's too bad
that's too bad
Jim it's even difficult to get any kind
of play here the king is coming up to
you 52 sister the issue
and at least I'm still somewhat active
it's not not super easy to win a thing
I'm not sure if I should have known
normally you should trade when you are
material down and maybe this is what I
should have done here as well but I
wanted to have that age six pawn as a
possible target time warning hmm nice
nicely played
charity will get geez geez geez mg4 yeah
I guess I want a toy a five well can
still can still fight absolutely
check
check 20 seconds
our age three will do the trick check I
am kind of hanging on but it's it's
losing now rookie Jack White it was
losing for a while yeah that was bad
that i blundered the pawn but it was a
funny funny situation there still I was
quite quite quite funny that the night
was trapped down Jim chatted it but it
is working what can you do did I have
something better rookie force better
it's not not without its points we
should have five queen age six yet clear
are ways to finish me off here for sure
here here you can improve it would be a
Don he he played to serve a bit too
quickly not taking this serious anymore
but after rookie form I'm probably very
ok they asked already allow Queen takes
age 7 and yeah right I just I just
blundered before yeah this is the
problem it was clear that I'm returning
the exchange here already but this is
this is Adeline that is pretty much
pretty much incorrect in in long time
control chairs that exchange sacrifice
but it's very difficult to play in blitz
it really is because of the dark squares
I've got all pawns on light squares and
black is having tricks all over the
place so what's a very good weapon for
blitz chess and what he played him yeah
this this was played to return the
exchange but it didn't work out this is
what the engine is giving yeah it makes
an awful lot of sense you had control
all those all those squares now those
kind of precise moves I'm are not so
easy to play in blitz chess this is a
set in a long time control game white
has good chances to extinguish blacks
initiative on the dark squares but this
is not easy to do in know in blitz time
controls check this and here I have to
take with the rook
just return or give give them give them
the porn here and back I wouldn't mind
that position to be honest it looks Jack
looks kind of okay I'm ready I'm happy
that the nights are out of the picture
of course that Bishop only five is ok
it's it's BER the rook in connection
with the with the porn but at least i'm
not getting checkmated with some some
nights but on the tag squares yeah damn
that's said uncomfortable and
uncomfortable opening to to face and in
blitz okay well thanks for watching